es ist die aufgabe des iwf lösungen zu
finden von denen alle profitieren ihre
umsetzbarkeit zu beweisen und dann die
g-20 davon zu überzeugen
china ist zwar die zweitstärkste
wirtschaftsmacht der welt aber auch
einer der ärmsten
diese krise ist ansteckend die angst
geht um und wir müssen sie auf weiten
ich möchte unsere regierung direkt sagen
dass sie mit der bevölkerung
zusammenarbeiten muss
der iwf wurde mit abscheu betrachtet man
rief diese wirtschafts schläger und die
setzen dass diktator
[Musik]
die geschichte mit dem schmetterling in
afrika der in lateinamerika wirbelstürme
auslöst bis den meisten geläufig genau
um so etwas geht es hier
die schattenseite der verbundenheit ist
alle sind schwankungen bemerkte
ausgesetzt
wir brauchen bessere multilaterale
führung hielt sie werden unsere kinder
und enkel den preis dafür bezahlen wie
du brauchst du
[Musik]
der iwf muss mit der zeit gehen er wurde
vor mehr als 60 jahren gegründet
dass er sich anpassen muss überrascht
wenig
in bretton woods new hampshire treffen
die delegierten aus 44 ländern der
alliierten zur eröffnung der un
finanzkonferenz 1 sie werden über pläne
für die währungsstabilität sprechen
die hoffnung und das ziel dabei war ein
besserer rahmen für die weltweite
zusammenarbeit
für gemeinsame problemlösungen und dass
die länder für ihre nationalen ziele
nicht die ziele der welt opfern würden
man wollte ein wirklich robustes und
stabiles system entwickeln
es bleibt dabei als unabdingbar die
freiheit der kapitalflüsse und des
marktes einzuschränken
heute geschieht alles unmittelbar und in
enormem maßstab
was auf dem europäischen oder dem
us-markt geschäft kann verheerende
folgen für bauern in afrika den bergbau
oder indigene völker in lateinamerika
haben diese verbundenheit hat viele
vorteile man beachtete nicht dass alles
gute auch schattenseiten haben könnte
die krise zeigt er uns wie groß diese
schattenseite sein könnte
man verstand nicht dass eine welle an
fehlern in wenig erforschten märkten die
weltwirtschaft in die knie zwingen
könnte
die prognosen eines büros zeigten es
würde sehr schlimm werden
als ich nach davos ging waren wir der
ansicht das würde sehr schlimm werden
auf globaler ebene wir würden weltweite
konjunkturpakete brauchen es wird zu
einer ernsten verlangsamung kommen die
eine ernste reaktion erforderte strauss
kahns rede in der wurst zeigte der welt
eine neue seite des iwf auch weil jemand
an der spitze diese dinge sagte
die leute sahen mich an als wäre ich ein
alien vom mars
es dauerte lange bis sie es
13 monate später im april 2008 waren wir
beim jährlichen frühlingstreffen in
washington meine prognose verärgerte die
finanzminister sie hielten es für einen
scherz
das sagten sie nicht so es war ja nicht
lustig sie sagten aber sie würden ihre
wirtschaft besser kennen als ich sie
waren sich sicher für sie würde alles
gut laufen mit meiner behauptung es
wurde noch schlimmer lege ich total
daneben
beim jährlichen treffen im oktober 2008
trafen sich leute aus verschiedensten
ländern und sagen endlich ein dass sie
ein gewaltiges gemeinsames problem
hatten
am montagmorgen konnte man am markt
erkennen dass washington signalisierte
die politischen entscheidungsträger
hätten verstanden
sie würden die nötigen massnahmen gegen
die erstarrung ergreifen und nach der
bewältigung der krise diese strukturen
reparieren
guten abend vom g20 gipfel in london
einem treffen auf der suche nach einer
globalen antwort der g20 gipfel in
london war einmalig 20 regierungschefs
der welt trafen aufeinander und
beschlossenen konjunkturpakete für die
weltwirtschaft in billionenhöhe
krisen zwinge menschen dazu ihre
differenzen hinter sich zu lassen und
probleme gemeinsam zu lösen
es war ein großes glück dass die
struktur der g20 und die große
hilfsbereitschaft des iwf
aufeinandertrafen
das handeln der zentralbanken auf der
monetären und der regierungen auf der
steuerlichen seite verhinderte eine
mögliche katastrophe
auf dem treffen in london belegten die
regierungschefs in gewisser weise den
iwf als multilaterale institutionen
mit der hoffnung dass dieser eine
gemeinsame antwort bieten könnte
der aktuelle aufstieg der g20 ist ein
zeichen dass die bedeutsamkeit
weltweiter wirtschaftlicher erholung und
des wachstums dieser sich entwickelnden
volkswirtschaften anerkannt wurde
brasilien china indien und andere sind
quasi das rückgrat des ganzen weltweiten
erholungsprozesses der
g20-gipfel verdreifachte die ressourcen
des iwf
einschließlich 50 milliarden dollar für
wirtschaftsschwache länder
es war meines wissens das erste mal
überhaupt in der weltgeschichte dass so
viele länder das gleiche problem hatte
und zeitgleich beschlossen auf die
gleiche weise dagegen vorzugehen
so gesehen stellt dieses bedeutsame
ereignis die erste multilaterale
maßnahme in dieser größenordnung dass
die g-20 haben ihre probleme ebenso der
iwf aber
immer mehr bewohner lisa eng vernetzten
welt verbinden mit diesen institutionen
die hoffnung auf fortschritte
der iwf wurde mit abscheu betrachtet das
absolut letzte finanzielle mittel seine
staat und regierung versagt hatten man
rief diese wirtschaft schläger und die
diktierten die regeln
mit afrika interagierte der iwf damals
üblicherweise nicht im dialog
die meisten länder darunter auch
tansania sahen darin folglich eine
alternativlose bittere pille
infolge der wirtschaftskrise musste sich
der iwf radikal ändern
denn die alten methoden waren
gescheitert
ich denke der iwf hat gelernt dass auch
gute wirtschaftliche ratschläge nicht
wirken wenn
sie politik und gesellschaft außer acht
lassen
[Musik]
die konferenz in tansania war teil eines
beratungsprozesses des iwf mit
verschiedenen teilen der welt afrika
hatte bei dem treffen klare ziele wir
hatten erwartet dass bei diesem treffen
die stimme von afrika gehört werden
würde
wenn man behördliches versagen in der
gleichen größenordnung wie in den usa in
einem afrikanischen staat hätte würde
der iwf über uns herfallen
ich war im laufe meiner karriere auf
einen derartigen konferenzen
dieses treffen war sehr ehrlich
wir erwarteten veränderungen vom iwf und
die gespräche auf dieser konferenz
drehten sich um genau diese probleme
der iwf hat die meisten seiner
veränderungs versprechen eingehalten
[Musik]
sie versprachen unter anderem einen
flexibleren umgang mit diesem partner
netzwerk
das wurde mittlerweile in den meisten
ländern offensichtlich umgesetzt
in gesprächen bemerkte ich die
veränderte einstellung der afrikanischen
finanzminister gegenüber dem iwf
sei den iwf als organisation die in
krisen helfen könnte anstatt zu
unterdrücken
das stigma das wohl viele länder in
asien nach der asienkrise verspürten als
der iwf ihnen in dieser schweren zeit im
weg standort wandelte sich während
dieser krise viele länder hatten den
eindruck der iwf würde ihnen jetzt
helfen
seien wir mal ehrlich
die ganzen nachwehen der asienkrise oft
geben sowie die nachwehen der
lateinamerikanischen schuldenkrise
aufgrund derer sich der iwf nur
schwerlich als globale institution der
alle angehören darstellen konnte
ich denke die haben wir wohl überwunden
wir haben dass
mein wunsch mein traum einer
koordinierten wirtschaft wird sich wohl
kaum über nacht erfüllen aber der
fortschritt geht die richtige richtung
guten abend nach 18 monaten überwindet
großbritannien die rezession eine
handvoll finanzbericht der weckt
hoffnungen auf eine wirtschaftliche
erholung
als sich die finanzkrise beruhigte
kehrten einige staaten zu ihren
nationalen plänen zurück und handelten
nicht mehr im einklang mit den plänen
anderer länder
warum hat die weltwirtschaft wieder
probleme die erholung verlangsamt sich
und die finanzmärkte werden wieder
nervös
es ist klar dass die lösung global und
nicht national erfolgen der iwf muss
also eine lösung finden von der alle
profitieren zeigen dass sie funktioniert
und dann die g20 und die regierung denn
allgemein davon überzeugen
wir brauchen eine institution die sich
tagtäglich mit diesem problem befasst
deren job es ist sich von früh bis spät
gedanken darüber zu machen und
kontinuierlich an der umsetzung zu
arbeiten
auf nationaler ebene geht es nicht
als sechster institution ist es den
regierungen souveräner staaten bei der
kommunikation mit einander zu helfen
so manchmal in ihre schranken zu
verweisen und ihren lesern auf lange
sicht etwas gutes zu tun
die sorge ist dass ohne echte
veränderungen in der politik nichts
voran gehen wird man muss auch an die
regierungen denken nicht nur an den iwf
der iwf war teil des problems
jetzt geht es darum wie sie teil einer
lösung werden
sie müssen proaktiv handeln die bank
sein die zuhört
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir können davon ausgehen dass
irgendwann vielleicht in der mitte des
jahrhunderts china 15 bis 20 prozent der
welt ausmachen wird ich halte das für
etwas gutes
wie kann china das aber aufrechterhalten
gibt es
china ist zwar die zweitstärkste
wirtschaftsmacht der welt aber auch eine
der ärmsten
[Musik]
wenn wir über die rolle des iwf in der
welt sprechen ist china ein sehr
erfolgreiches beispiel
[Musik]
hatte in den letzten 30 jahren jedes
jahr ein wachstum von etwa 9,5 prozent
denn zufolge verdoppelt sich die
wirtschaftsleistung chinas etwa alle
acht jahre
so hat ist china seit den reformen schon
1979 vor über 30 jahren von an die
ärmsten länder zur zweitstärksten
wirtschaftsmacht der welt geworden
ich bin der chinesischen volksbank in
den frühen 1990 er jahren beigetreten am
anfang des wechsels von einer
planwirtschaft seiner marktorientierten
wirtschaft
das war eine gewaltige herausforderung
der iwf verfügt über einen großen
erfahrungsschatz
der iwf arbeitete sehr eng und positiv
mit china zusammen über viele jahre
hinweg einige unserer mitarbeiter sind
dort stationiert das ist seit über 20
jahren so die ratschläge des iwf ein
china basierten auf dem was wir in
anderen ländern beobachteten die
ähnliche probleme hatten
china hat viel für erfolgreiche reformen
getan
dabei hat der iwf eine sehr konstruktive
und positive rolle gespielt
der hauptvorteil des chinesischen
wachstums liegt wohl im starken rückgang
der armut in china
[Musik]
anfang der 1980 er jahre lebten über 50
prozent der menschen in china in
bitterer armut
heute sind es weniger als acht prozent
hochgerechnet auf beinahe anderthalb
milliarden menschen in china wurden über
400 millionen menschen aus der armut
befreit
das besondere am chinesischen modell
lässt die starke führung durch den staat
das zeigte sich besonders bei der
reaktion auf die krise
man brachte ein beinahe einmaliges
steuerliches konjunkturpaket hervor
auch die finanziellen und monetären
maßnahmen waren erstaunlich
wir unterstützen die reaktionen wir
glauben das konjunkturpaket der
regierung hat geholfen
es kam zur rechten zeit und half die
schlimmsten folgen für die wirtschaft
abzufedern
chinas exporte brachen ein und die
regierung hat der einschreiten um die
wirtschaftsleistung zu stützen
sie taten das durch investitionen in
straßen in infrastruktur und das
gesundheitswesen wodurch sie ihr
angestrebtes wachstum erreichten
[Musik]
viele unserer klienten profitierten von
den konjunkturpaketen wie benefit wir
genauso wie
darum ist jetzt schon seit jahren
kontinuierlich weiter gewachsen
die größte herausforderung für china ist
es die abhängigkeit von ausländischer
nachfrage zu verringern
aktuell ist die nachfrage in china viel
zu niedrig der binnenkonsum ist selbst
global betrachtet auf einem historischen
tiefstand
ich habe den eindruck die chinesischen
behörden wissen dass sie das wachstum
neuer balance ihr müssen weg vom
gewaltigen fokus auf export und pinsel
inländische nachfrage insbesondere beim
privaten verbrauch die finanzmärkte
auszubauen wird wichtig sein ebenso wie
eine starke währung der wechselkurs ist
ein wichtiger baustein für reformen um
die wirtschaft neu auszubalancieren
prinzipiell konzentrieren wir uns darauf
den konsum zu fördern und den aufbau der
dienstleistungsbranche zu unterstützen
wenn man viel in sozialleistungen renten
programme medizin programme für
ländliche regionen und dergleichen
investiert wird man ergebnis erzielen
der inländische verbrauch der
einzelhandel und die binnennachfrage
werden steigern
ein grund für den geringen konsum in
china ist die sorge der menschen um ihre
altersvorsorge die fehlende
krankenversicherung und die befürchteten
ausgaben für die bildung ihrer kinder
[Musik]
wir sind froh wenn wir gesund sind
werden wir krank brauchen wir geld fürs
krankenhaus
darum sparen wir jeden monat etwas geht
als ich jung war hatte ich nicht genug
zum sparen
ich dachte nicht im traum daran hätte
wofür sollte ich auch sparen
[Musik]
ich erlebte in meiner kindheit die
planwirtschaft das leben war damals sehr
hart es gab aber nur wenig druck wir
waren alle in der gleichen lage
für die trennung von arm und reich war
damals nicht allzu ausgeprägt
die einkommensungleichheit in china war
früher sehr flach ist heute aber
ziemlich ausgeprägt das fällt besonders
in einem land auf in dem es vor einigen
jahrzehnten eben keine
einkommensungleichheit gab
[Musik]
china ist ein entwicklungsland und wird
noch lange ein entwicklungsland leiden
wir müssen die entwicklung
wissenschaftlich betrachten und unser
wachstum dann nachhaltig und ausgewogen
gestalten
china ist besorgt dass es im hinblick
auf das einkommen nicht das obere
mittelfeld erreichen könnte sie machen
sich sorgen dass ihr wachstum einbricht
und sie nicht verletzten 100 millionen
menschen aus der armut befreien können
sie haben die typischen sorgen eines
entwicklungslandes
[Musik]
die anstrengungen der regierung das
rentensystem massiv auszuweiten und die
öffentliche gesundheitsversorgung zu
verbessern sind schritte in die richtige
richtung die wir unterstützen
es stehen noch viele weitere schwierige
maßnahmen an allen voran die lage der
wanderarbeiter
[Musik]
ich kam 2009 nach chancen und verdient
den 900 yuan als mindestlohn jetzt sind
es 1100 wir geben aber knapp 300 für
essen ausrufen die erhöhung ist ein witz
aber
viele firmen leute einstellen viele
leute suchen arbeit der konkurrenzkampf
ist
das gehalt es nicht gut die
unterbringung und das angebotene essen
ebenso wenig ganz besonders die
unterbringung oft stehen mehrere
mitgenommene betten in einem winzigen
raum die betten in manchen fabriken sind
voller flöhe
china wurde in
die politik ging mit der spaltung
zwischen stadt und land so um dass die
integration ländlicher bevölkerungen
vereinfacht wurde
wodurch diese besser von der stadt
profitieren können
china könnte als verbrauchermarkt zur
triebfeder der weltwirtschaft werden
doch die probleme der wanderarbeiter und
die art wie verhindert wird dass sie in
stetten sesshaft werden sind hierbei ein
großes hindernis
chinas konsum ist zu niedrig die
fehlannahme besteht darin den konsum als
gesondertes problem zu betrachten das
unabhängig von großen reformen am
wachstumsmodell gelöst werden kann
dementsprechend muss die gleichheit
gefördert werden
produktivität anstatt billiger arbeit
innovation anstatt den bloßen export
möglichst vieler güter in alle welt all
das erfordert viel besser ausgebaute und
transparentere formelle institutionen
damit investoren und haushalte sich
trauen zu investieren und innovation
ausgaben und konsum wagen
[Musik]
die herausforderung besteht darin
dass das bruttoinlandsprodukt von china
zwar jedes jahr wächst
wir aber mehr und mehr durch
einschränkungen gebunden werden
insbesondere im hinblick auf ressourcen
energie und umwelt aufschlagen
durch die anpassung an andere länder
infolge des chinesischen wachstums wird
china einigung als bedrohung erscheinen
es wird immer deutlicher dass chinas
wachstum auf andere länder überschwappt
der iwf bietet hierbei ein forum um
politische differenzen zu besprechen
[Musik]
der iwf war eine entscheidende
internationale plattform über die die
internationale gemeinschaft china besser
kennen lernen konnte
während china mehr über den rest der
welt erfahren konnte
[Musik]
es ist eine goldgrube
aber niemand weiß wie lang die ölvorräte
halten werden
wir sehen das öl als
zweite chance für das land
die regierung gerät unter druck
ich möchte unsere regierung direkt sagen
dass sie mit der bevölkerung
zusammenarbeiten muss
[Musik]
2007 hieß es in den nachrichten dass er
in ghana herausragende ölvorräte
gefunden worden waren wobei die größe
des ölfelds noch ungewiss war es war
aber klar das kann er sich den
afrikanischen öllieferanten anschließen
würde
wenn die öl förderung läuft steigt das
einkommen in ghana wahrscheinlich um
etwa 20 prozent die steuereinnahmen
werden 56 prozent vom
bruttoinlandsprodukt ausmachen das ist
enorm denn ghana hat gerade große
geldnot
[Musik]
2008 hatten wir nicht nur
schwierigkeiten aufgrund der
weltwirtschaftskrise wir hatten auch
selbst viel viel größere schwierigkeiten
mit der internen verwaltung unserer
eigenen wirtschaft
2008 wurde gewählt
in wahljahren geht in unserem teil der
welt immer die haushaltsdisziplin verlor
am jahresende war das haushaltsdefizit
auf einem rekordhoch beinahe 20 prozent
dazu kam auch noch ein handelsdefizit
von fast 20
in anbetracht dieser schwierigkeiten
hatten wir keine andere wahl als den iwf
um stabilisierungs hilfe zu bitten
der iwf ist seit langem wichtig für
ghana
es gab dabei probleme aber wir hatten
auch gute zeiten
manchmal kamen dabei programm heraus die
nie wirklich beliebt waren aber
letztendlich brauchte ghana den iwf
einfach und
die finanzhilfen beliefen sich auf etwas
über eine milliarde us-dollar
und der iwf könnte auf der anderen seite
auch die technischen hilfen erhöhen die
ghana erhält
der iwf kam nach ghana und fragte dort
was die menschen und die regierung
wollten
sie stellten weniger bedingungen als bei
der finanzierung ghanas in den 1980 er
jahren die lage war ganz anders die
regierung von präsident mills übernahm
2009 ein land mit vielen problemen aber
die wirtschaftslage war nicht
aussichtslos
er hat viel erfahrung bei der beratung
von ländern in afrika südlich der sahara
und anderen ländern und reichen
ölvorräten
daher ghana mit praktischer erfahrung
helfen zu können ghana war geradezu
erpicht darauf von anderen ländern zu
lernen
[Musik]
eine abhängigkeit von rohmaterialien
oder natürlichen rohstoffen führt nicht
seine verwandlung der wirtschaftlich
trotz unserer gewaltigen gold vorkommen
konnten wir die so sehr erhoffte
wirtschafts transformation nicht
erreichen
das bringt nichts wenn der durchschnitts
gar keine bildung bekommt
das öl bringt nichts wenn die menschen
keine gute gesundheitsversorgung im
krankenhaus bekommen können
alles öl der welt bringt nichts wenn
viel zu viele junge mütter bei der
geburt ihrer kinder sterben
die erste aufgabe ist die verwandlung
der wirtschaft dahingehend dass
wertschöpfung stattfindet und wir mehr
mittel bekommen um die wirtschaft zu
betreiben und den lebensstandard der
bürger zu verbessern sie auszubilden
sozialkapital zu erschaffen und für
bildung wasser gesundheit und
infrastruktur zu sorgen
es ist für die kanarische regierung sehr
wichtig investitionen mit hoher gewinn
wahrscheinlichkeit zu finden
damit auch wenn das ende der ölförderung
kommt diese investitionen weiterhin
gewinne abwerfen
[Musik]
richtig genutzt kann das öl den rest der
wirtschaft ankurbeln
wir müssen unseren ansatz völlig ändern
und verstehen dass wir zwar natürliche
ressourcen haben unser größter schatz
jedoch all die menschen in unserem land
sind
[Musik]
in ghana wird debattiert wie mehr ghana
in die ölindustrie eingebunden werden
können man redet dabei von lokalen
inhalten
ich habe das projekt gestartet weil ich
glaube dass junge leute die möglichkeit
brauchen an der neuen öl- und
gasindustrie die hier entsteht
teilzuhaben und mitzuarbeiten
ich bin maschinenbauingenieur brauche
aber noch training um in der öl und
gasindustrie arbeiten zu können
wenn man menschen möglichkeiten gibt
werden sie wertvolle bürger ansonsten
werden sie ein problem für die gesamte
gesellschaft
wir haben viele jugendliche hier in der
region und bitten das gesamte land und
die regierung den jugendlichen hier
arbeit zu geben
wir sind ein entwicklungsland und
relativ arm die menschen können es nicht
erwarten die armut und die
unterentwicklung abzuschütteln die
erwartungshaltung ist da nur
verständlich
es ist in allen regionen das gleiche wir
müssen vielmehr auf bildung setzen
vermitteln dass sich die situation der
menschen hier nicht über nacht ändern
hat
es muss ein schrittweiser prozess sein
wir haben viel aufwand betrieben um
einige schwierigkeiten und regierungs
anstrengungen diesbezüglich zu erklären
natürlich hören wir auch auf die sorgen
der bevölkerung
ist ein nachwachsender rohstoff
wir wissen nicht wie lange ghana will
fördern kann also ist nicht nur die
ölbranche wichtig
es wäre wohl wichtig die gewinne aus der
ölförderung in unterstützung für
kleinbauern zu investieren
[Applaus]
landwirtschaft ist ein hauptelement
unserer wirtschaft sie beschäftigt die
meisten menschen hier viele sind auf sie
angewiesen
sie leistet den größten beitrag zum
bruttoinlandsprodukt
die landwirtschaft in ghana war früher
vollständig subventionierte anteil
subventioniert und irgendwann bekam in
die bauern gar keine subventionen mehr
wir brauchen dünger wir brauchen geld
wir müssen die felder bereiten und dann
brauchen wir pflanzen die wir anbauen
können
das geld ist wichtig denn ohne geld
können wir weder dünger noch pestizide
kaufen
wir bekommen keinen kredit wir können
keine gentechnik nutzen auch wenn wir
die technologie fördern wollen
kredite sind der schlüssel wenn wir die
ghanaische landwirtschaft weiter
entwickeln wollen
[Musik]
in anderen ländern in denen öl ein
faktor war ging der agrarsektor unter
man muss seine wirtschaft so verwalten
können dass das öl welches nur wenig
arbeit schafft andere bereiche nicht
beeinträchtigt die menschen beschäftigen
und vor der armut bewahren
bei einem öl bleibt der bereich der
konsumgüter wie zb die kakao branche auf
der strecke
wir ergreifen jedoch maßnahmen damit
dass hier nicht passiert
das öl wird fließen aber wir müssen
unsere traditionelle lebensweise
bewahren
[Musik]
garner überall verlangen nach
transparenz sie wollen keine korruption
sie wollen nicht dass die gewinne aus
dem öl der willkür der menschen in der
regierung zum opfer fallen
wir haben mit ghana daran gearbeitet die
haushaltung zu verbessern und sowohl dem
parlament als auch der zivilgesellschaft
als ganzes einverständnis ihrer finanzen
der verteilung ihrer ressourcen zu
vermitteln
wir wollen ghana bis 2020 zu einem land
mit mittlerem einkommen machen
aber die regierung muss sehr zielstrebig
und diszipliniert darauf hinarbeiten
[Musik]
wenn es uns gelingen soll werden wir das
öl als impulsgeber für die ersehnte
transformation brauchen
vielleicht werden wir dann zu einem
positiven beispiel und eine inspiration
für ganz afrika
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mittel- und osteuropa hat die finanz und
wirtschaftskrise wohl schlimmer erwischt
als den rest der welt
allerdings mit ausnahme von polen
polen ist als einziges eu land nicht in
eine rezession gefallen
polen hat die chance nicht weniger als
eine europäische wirtschaftsmacht zu
werden
die solidar schweigert ihrem neunten
geburtstag
sie hat die polnische politik informiert
und führt nun die regierung
das versprechen von 1989 war das ende
der sozialen spaltung mit dem ende des
kalten kriegs
nach 1989 waren wir alle der meinung es
gebe nur einen unausweichlichen weg eine
richtung
wir hatten keine zeit für debatten denn
wir mussten zu westlichen ländern
aufholen
polen hat er eine große krise hinter
sich und musste einen weg finden sich in
die moderne welt einzufügen die gesamte
wirtschaft struktur ändern und
wettbewerbsfähig werden eine
kapitalistische westliche wirtschaft
aufbauen
man kommt nicht umhin zu sagen dass
viele die änderung des systems freudig
begrüßt
gleichzeitig waren sie überrascht weil
sie viel zu plötzlich die volle
verantwortung für ihr leben übernehmen
mussten
für gebildete menschen den großen
städten die jung genug waren um sich auf
dem markt zu behaupten weiß großartig
aber ein großer teil der gesellschaft
die außen vor und wurde frustriert
die arbeitslosenzahl wird dieses jahr
eine million erreichen das arbeitsamt in
warschau ist ausgelastet wie noch nie
vor einem jahr war fast niemand
arbeitslos gemeldet jetzt gibt es in
polen 400.000 arbeitssuchende
fielen viele schwer wieder arbeit zu
finden und die die es nicht schafften
wurden an den rand der gesellschaft
gedrängt sie waren
die verlierer die chance dass es
funktionieren würde war in dokumenten
des iwf auf 50 prozent beziffert worden
die politik war jedoch fest entschlossen
und hatte den mut es durchzuziehen wir
hatten keine andere wahl als diese
mutigen reformen zu unterstützen
wir werden ihrer regierung bei der
gestaltung ihrer programme helfen
es ist die aufgabe des iwf in solchen
fällen mit unserem wissen und unserer
erfahrung bezüglich dieser probleme zu
helfen
es war nicht nur die kommunistische
wirtschaft es fehlte auch die kompetenz
eine marktwirtschaft zu betreiben
auf technischer seite war die hilfe
unbedingt nötig
[Musik]
für mich war das großartig denn wenn
jemand eine gute idee und ein wenig geld
hatte war das eine große chance etwas
auf die beine zu stellen
es ging nicht nur um geld
spirituell für uns wichtig dass unsere
produkte unseren kunden helfen
die menschen den polen waren schon immer
sehr individualistisch
sie machten es nicht herum kommentiert
zu werden
wenn man sein eigener bosses kommandiert
eine niemand herum
ich habe diese firma vor 20 jahren mit
meinem partner in einer garage gegründet
zu zweit
wir nutzten damals nur bargeld
geld wechselte schnell den besitzer
wir konnten neue dinge und maschinen
kaufen
es war sehr einfach
darum ging es in polen bei fast allen
wirtschaftlichen
unternehmensbereich und normal zu werden
der anfängliche erfolg kam vom
polnischen unternehmers der große
schritt vorwärts kam jedoch dadurch dass
polen für investitionen attraktiv wurde
der markt entwickelte sich das
warenangebot wurde immer reichhaltiger
wir hatten so viele jahre langen
hausgemachte armut gelebt dass wir es
sehr genossen
jetzt wird alles in polen hergestellt
und zwar von ausländischen marken aber
die produkte kommen von hier
unser wachstum war nicht allzu
beeindruckend die ersten jahre lagen wir
- aber nach einer weile wuchs die
wirtschaft immer schneller bisher mitte
der 1990 er jahre sieben prozent
wachstum erreicht
eines der länder beim empfang zur
erweiterung der eu war polen das größte
der zehn neu beigetretenen länder was
aber bedeutet die eu mitgliedschaft für
die menschen dort in
polen war der wunsch nach arbeit und bei
einem normalen wohlhabenden lang france
zitaten alles dafür und erreichten jetzt
alle wollten der eu beitreten spanischen
langers unser schicksal
wir wollten auch dazu gehören
[Musik]
die transformation war sehr schnell und
umfassend
heute haben die meisten sich damit
angefreundet aber damals gab es ganz
klar verlierer
[Musik]
beim wechsel vom sozialismus zu einer
marktwirtschaft wächst die ungleichheit
natürlich immer
das beispiel polens zeigt jedoch dass
die länder die sich am schnellsten
reformierten den geringsten zuwachs der
ungleichheit erlebten
der kollaps der lehman brothers versetzt
die wall street in panik
die ganze welt spielte verrückt
was wir an den börsen in new york london
und warschau beobachteten
tanken wir nicht verstehen
wir wurden nervös
wir beobachteten ist
die erste reaktion der regierung war die
beschränkung der ausgaben
die finanzkrise hat uns nicht gut getan
wir sind schließlich exporteure
insbesondere nach osten zum beispiel
nach russland und in die ukraine
es gab durchaus probleme
hat ein grösseres haushaltsdefizit
höherer staatsschulden aber fürs erste
lied die realwirtschaft in polen nicht
ebensowenig der banksektor
man hat wohl als einziges land die
neuverschuldung in der verfassung an das
bruttoinlandsprodukt geknüpft
das trug maßgeblich zu geringen
verschuldung bei sie uns gemeinsam mit
verantwortungsvoller steuerpolitik in
eine solide finanzielle lage brachte
wir waren nicht durch die guten jahre
vor der krise unvorsichtig geworden
kohl verfolgte eine stabilere politik
als seine nachbarn doch wir waren
besorgt dass die krise von unseren
nachbarstaaten überschwappen würde
eine solche krise ist wirklich an steckt
eine krise der angst die angst
überwältigt zuerst die schwächsten und
befällt dann die stärke
man muss die angst aufhalten und das
geht nur durch internationalen
zusammenhalt
[Musik]
polen war in einer stärkeren position
als die anderen länder
darum griff der iwf polen mit
unterstützung über die flexible
kreditlinie unter die arme holen war der
ideale kandidat
ein politisch starkes land auf dass die
krise der nachbarstaaten dennoch
überzugreifen drohte
es ist schon furcht erregend dass
manchmal entscheidungen ohne kenntnis
der situation in einem bestimmten land
getroffen werden
es war der perfekte zeitpunkt für den
iwf sein neues instrument zu nutzen
polen galt als starke wirtschaft mit
einem soliden fundament
was zusätzlich half und der regierung
eine bessere verhandlungsbasis bei
investoren gut auf dem markt gab
an den fakten hat sich nichts geändert
aber die wahrnehmung dieser fakten ist
anders die flexible kreditlinie war ein
klares zeichen dass der iwf an polen
glaubte und somit auch an die ganze
region
diese krise war eine einmalige chance
wir dachten es würde vielleicht 30 40
jahre dauern bis wir zu unseren brüdern
in der eu ausschließen können würden
ihre rezession und unserem stabilen
wachstum werden wir dieses ziel
schneller erreichen können
aus der erfahrung mit polen haben wir
gelernt dass politische
entscheidungsträger erstaunliches
leisten können wenn sie in einer
schwierigen lage den mut haben zu
handeln
[Musik]